well what's that niche boy hd for
president watch me on the bullet kill
podcast
all right yo bootleg cab show we got a
special guest in here uh this guy's got
one of the biggest songs on tik tok
right now one of the big songs in the
world all right uh
baton rouge
is in the building hd for president i'm
in the building welcome
welcome man i just had um
quite possibly the greatest rapper to
ever come out of baton rouge up here
live a couple weeks ago boozy was up
here oh boo it's my boy yeah i mean [ __ ]
the song's called his mama called me
this morning song's called touch
touchdown yeah i'm gonna say that's like
that's a boozy [ __ ] yeah yeah so um
first of all
the song is so big
and it's it's you know with tick-tock
you just never know what works on
tick-tock so how did you kind of like
when was the first time when you kind of
figured out this [ __ ] was going viral
man the same we got dropped it like
two days later they sent me a link
and the link had like
maybe like four six thousand videos but
it was going up every hour a thousand an
hour wow and i'm like maybe i'm tripping
so i'm refreshing like nah i'm not
tripping
and then that's when i call my memories
i'm like hey this song's going crazy on
tick tock but i ain't have a tick tock
so you didn't even have a ticket no i
heard it when we made me a little tick
tock trying to keep up with it and
before i knew they had like six links
you know tick tock's like a thing like
if you're a grown ass man it's hard to
get a
because i'm like tick
i'm growing i ain't no [ __ ] tick-tock
yeah i don't need not a work to tell you
i don't know how to make a video you
know it's an art to it too right right
yeah tick-tock is like a art i feel like
they should be teaching like rappers
should go to tick-tock class oh yeah i
mean and have like a 14 year old teach
it after i did it i seen a lot of people
trying to go through the tic-tac-toe
right they was even paying the people
who was going viral
for my song i i look up and i see them
peeing somebody from that's what that's
what's best about what shoot is just how
organic yeah i ain't even paid for it
that's a beautiful thing now when this
song started to take off where you
independently already with motown i was
independent so this song starts to go
crazy all the labels are probably
calling yeah i have been talking with
motown for like real talking for like
six months so you're already talking to
them already trying to get the deal done
with touchdown but it was a different
version
so we had issues with the it was it was
gonna be a feature
with another artist we was having issues
getting the song over to the label
they're like hey send us a touchdown
record we love it
and i went and remade it i was like so
once the record started to go viral your
leverage went up my leverage went holy
cow
of course
yeah so what what um with with all the
offers coming in outside of motown what
made you turn down everybody else was it
the fact that they were already [ __ ]
with you the whole time did and it's
just like the history of motion like
my favorite movie was probably the
temptations mm-hmm so the legendary
already the history already was done so
when i got you know he was already
talking with him and
you know keno he had been working with
me i had another song called mouth full
of goals
that was catching steam too he loved
and it was like you know saying it was
just the right decision um
baton rouge i always say like there's
like a few cities
that are running hip-hop and right now
it feels like it's baton rouge and and
memphis
goes to beach are the two
like leading the pack as far as like
where everyone else is going like you
know what i'm saying like atlanta's had
it for so long right but i feel like
it's baton rouge in this memphis now
yeah memphis they're going but baton
rouge is going hard too man we go we got
a young boy you know
what do you like and the other thing too
about where you're from is i feel like
there's so much internal
behavior and drama there's a lot of
drama amongst the artists it's a lot i
was thinking i wish they can change the
narrative
the crazy thing about it i knew all them
guys
before the
you know the conflicts right right so i
just really stayed neutral in the whole
thing but
if we can get past the beef y'all will
see a whole lot of motel
yeah because i was talking to busy and i
was like uh you know he's his uh cousin
is fredo bang yeah but they can't make
money they can't make music together
because of the politics
the back history behind who he deals
with yeah it's crazy and it's
unfortunate
because a lot of that [ __ ]
used to happen here in l.a you know
you couldn't do records with certain
artists wouldn't work together not
because they got personal [ __ ] it's just
the neighborhoods they're from yeah
that's what it is you know
you know i i mean i don't you're you're
not wrapped up in any of that drama no
i'm i'm cool with all all reporters i
ain't got nothing to do and then you
know
i don't involve myself with and i tell
them though like like look
at another dude with y'all situation you
know
if y'all want to work when we can work
you said that you talked to uh boosie's
mom called you this
one what's your relationship with his
mom and she loved him and she loved me
we're moving on my eyes all week right
about the boosted bags because i tell
him i'm gonna be able to make it oh
you're not going i'm going oh at first i
i wouldn't be able to make it because i
had a show
in texas but it was on your head about
it
hd you know it needs me i read it to me
he was i ran into him
i think friday thursday
and i kind of slipped i slipped through
the crease and i knew this would ask me
about it and he called me back hey it's
a crazy lineup he's got oh he's crazy
little baby the baby uh
moose
i mean it's a wild lineup it's crazy
it's just like it was like it's like a
three-day thing though i mean it makes
sense for you to be honest that's your
[ __ ] you know that's my city so we got
it we got to figure it out to where i
can be there and still make it to texas
but then this one this morning when i
was in the hotel his mama called me but
you know what i'm calling you for like
no what you got me for he was like i
need you to come to the school friday
right before the boosie beds the kids
want to see you so i like i'm gonna make
it happen that's crazy how's how's so
you've known have you known like
boosie's family yeah i've been we've
been locked in that's just wild to have
like you know his mom called me yeah
we've been locked in for 10 plus years
that's beautiful so you're obviously not
a new artist this is you've been how
long have you been active doing the rap
[ __ ] i've been really rapping since the
90s literally since the 90s i had my
first deal when i was 11. but i passed
up on
wow i'm 31.
so last 20 years right there's just
steady working that's crazy so
you've seen a lot man yeah i've been on
the road i mean i haven't been on the
road with booster like
years ago did you ever did you ever
think about signing with him because you
know
nah like
it's my boy but you know you know saying
like
i can't see me signing you know we we we
we move right from here appear here's a
piece yeah like we're friends like we
two bosses yeah i'm saying two
we two bosses so
i just i just soaked up a lot of games
from like i i learned from his hustle
like watching him do three four shows a
night i was crazy on the road when he
got out of jail i never seen like uh
man the bags he was grabbing i watched
him when he first got out i was living
in tampa at the time he was getting i
did not understand cause i'm a west
coast guy but i did radio in tampa for
three years
and i didn't understand
what busy meant to the south until i
lived there and i and i was living there
when he got out the impact he got on
himself is unmissed and it's crazy how
people got really offended when he put
out the boot pack album but i'm like bro
loki he's a lot of people's tupac yeah
yeah yeah
to us he would see he was too about this
yeah like coming up we man
ain't a lot coming up that's all we knew
was boosting
booster was the man something about the
pain the pain that pain like yeah you
would be you would be made and you have
to go put that booze on just
help your mood you know saying you're
dealing with some issues
you're struggling in life
just go put that boots on you're gonna
you're gonna either go get up and go
hustle are you gonna let some steam out
right
[ __ ] i know [ __ ] gonna slide today
whatever you gotta do like it's
boosting his boots like he to me um
20 years in
this is your first big big like national
hit right a lot of people
would not last 20 years before they
decided to go do some other [ __ ]
right right how uh
how how how how good does it feel to
have it all pay off
it's a blessing right you got two
watches on by the way that's how that's
how well you're doing yeah caught
saying they caught into rolling yeah i
had this before the deal though okay
okay okay yeah i ain't never i haven't
spent a dollar for my deal well congrats
to you i've been running straight
running them up
yeah i mean
i'm sure you've been killing it
independently for a minute yeah i've
been there i've been running it up
running it up way before the day he was
running it up
but it feel good though like see to see
it paying off because
a lot of people gave up on me i never
had no team i just didn't me
like i was just telling earlier like how
when i dropped the can't stop jigging
record the original one that blew up
first like people don't know that
everybody a little touchdown but can't
stop jigging over 15 million streams wow
yeah see that was the one that really
kicked off the whole thing and even when
we
did do touchdown we put can't stop
jigging at the beginning
so the blah blah blah they come from uh
original record yeah yeah so with that
record i was just
putting together videos on instagram
just find somebody dancing put the video
together and just keep on posting it
until it
caught people's attention and then it
started going viral what was the feature
you were talking about earlier where you
had to redo the song who was supposed to
be on on on the original version on one
of my one of my homeboys his name
playboy exo okay
he he sent me uh he sent me an open song
with just a verse
and i put the hook in the verse on it
and then when the label was like they
love it mozarella hey we love this song
but then it was like he was like he
already had a hook for the song he
wanted to use so he ended up taking my
hook off that song and you used it and i
just used that hook and we wrote and
wrote and made a new uh first verse like
the second verse was already
on the song right but the the the first
verse i just came with a whole nother
energy to the song um for people who are
watching this man like what would be you
know
aspiring artists right who maybe have
been grinding independently and ain't
ain't really getting no traction what
would be some advice you would give them
is somebody who's
stayed down and like you said you have
you know outside of this record you had
another record that was really big you
know what i mean
keep working keep working and believing
yourself if that's what you think
if in your heart you feel like that's
what you're supposed to do
keep working because you got to believe
in yourself you got to believe in
yourself when i was
i i remember like
i think tupac had just died
and i told my mom i'm gonna be a rapper
like
what you're gonna be when you grow up
everybody hey i said i'm gonna be a
rapper astronaut
it was one of the two i don't be a
rapper or an astronaut it's the only two
things i ever wanted to be so
i knew i was going to be a rapper for
sure at what point in time did you
realize being an astronaut would
probably be the toughest man probably
like probably like a day later
and not a lot of those
yeah i realized it was kind of i was
kind of low-key you know
you might be able to pay to go to space
soon enough it's looking like it's
happening that way i think there was
jeff bezo yeah yeah i think it's like
200 grand or something like that to go
up to space or something isn't it like
250 000
i think it's more than it might be more
but you know if you got the money i mean
that i mean if you're gonna [ __ ] i'm
saying when i see you go i thought about
it that's like would you rather like buy
a phantom or go to space
i'm buying a fence yeah i'm going to
space [ __ ] that no i go to space i
thought i got enough money to buy the
family but i ain't going if i got enough
money i'll drive i'll drive the the the
the camry i mean and then go to space
technically you're in space in the in
the film because you got the stars right
no that's that's that's
the that's the reef well whatever it is
it's not the same
hey i'll be like [ __ ] i went to space
but
it's a hundred k is it
decades right now it's worth it
a decade
i mean if you're making that kind of
money i would rather have the space trip
than
like yeah i mean i i go to space i don't
know
i don't think they really went though
they went too fast
yeah like they just went and came back
to where that yeah what he did was
different i'm trying to go out there and
can't hang out you want to dug it out
went to the moon yeah you're trying to
go i'm trying to go touch that spike
with you to get a resort yeah i ain't
trying to go jump out and come back
anywhere any worth of money i think
they're gonna end up with hotels up
there yes yeah
i think it's life on other planets i
don't know i was just talking to my boy
i think there's aliens here
i think they do that i know i believe in
mermaids for sure mermaids they real
well i think aliens are in the ocean
aliens this i get they're saying say
anything really i think memory is real i
don't care what woman well is there some
sort of uh thing you saw that made you
did you see her mermaid no i just i
don't know sun in my mind it like
certain [ __ ] be in my mind
did i believe would you smash a mermaid
if she find the one i see on that movie
that i watch
i'll definitely go uh you throw a
mermaid today
i put that [ __ ] on
that when i see y'all ain't never seen
that move with the mermaid in it i saw
it like in the 80s 90s the old movie
it was fine what was it called splash
right something yeah splash yeah you
wouldn't either i mean i mean listen i'm
married but hypothetically if my wife
was a mermaid i'd [ __ ] her
i [ __ ] a wife version of a mermaid
no i think there's aliens did you see
the video where there's like a ufo is
from a navy ship and it's like in the
sky and then go straight down in the
ocean yeah i've seen it that [ __ ] is
real i think i think it's real
if you found out aliens were real
like definitively yeah how much would it
like [ __ ] up i see you got like jesus on
your chain right yeah if we knew aliens
were real and it kind of like
i feel like it would [ __ ] up a lot of
people's principles oh how do you think
because if we knew there was like
universes everywhere kind of like
it kind of like pokes a lot of holes in
like religion and a lot of beliefs
religion don't stay strong no more right
because we're like one thing
in the sky there's a heaven might not be
up there yeah so we haven't really yeah
it's like or is it all you know i don't
know
it's deadly it'll be crazy i think that
can be real i think i don't know if
we're ready man i think it's a lot of
[ __ ] we ain't seen with the [ __ ] that i
don't disagree i think what they're
doing right now is because there's so
much crazy [ __ ] in the world that we're
worried about coronavirus
all kinds of wild shits happening right
you notice they've been throwing this
little bones
like barack said that ufos are real yeah
people didn't even really battle eye at
that right and the cia said that they're
real then they've been putting out these
little videos they're moving out are
they moving in these slowly
getting this ready man
i believe it i'm all i'm i'm all fooled
aliens come out they gotta be an alien
rapper we ain't we ain't we ain't
explored the whole earth which if if
there was like let's say aliens were
here and we we didn't know it yeah if
you had to put your money on a rapper
who was secretly an alien who would it
be
uh 100 000. that's fair
he kind of looked like an alien
and he he different he do alien [ __ ]
he's a he's an alien as an emcee for his
videos in his music he's one of a kind
i'ma go who would be like an alien
i wouldn't be surprised if e40 was an
alien
[Music]
yeah e40 the alien that'd be kind of
fire
that would be crazy um all right so the
song is going crazy is there going to be
an official remix yeah it's on the way
who's on it
okay just give me one give me one
can you say hey i think i might get a
joke okay give me a city that they're
from and i'll guess
they're from italy
that's the easiest [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right let's see if i can guess
atlanta
damn what'd you say atlanta man i was
hoping you're gonna say like
jacksonville or some [ __ ] saint pete i'd
be like oh broadway
[ __ ]
i don't even know man who's from atlanta
cook that's i mean besides the migos i
mean who two chains two chains is on the
remix it's two chains
no it's two chains it is it's it's
definitely two two chains getting on
every one [ __ ] right now
so so two changes on the remix how you
say that i ain't confirmed it's two
chains i ain't confirmed i can't wait to
hear it how to chain slides on that
i ain't good for you
hey the way i said it and he pointed at
me he's like this [ __ ]
guess number one nailed it
god damn
oh [ __ ] shane's been getting on all
kinds of [ __ ] it's definitely two
chances let me find out he he he got
some inside mo is it multiple
mc's from atlanta
uh
no there's just one for me
what about the other city
give me another series
the other artists on the song the other
remix artist what city are they from
uh one from baton rouge
i mean it's alfredo bang
oh my god two for two
because boozy you i mean boozy that's
easy that's like low-hanging fruit you
could get busy on the remix the song's
named after some [ __ ] but fredo bangla
makes sense
he's got a [ __ ] big wreck it's fredo
banging two chance the remix is coming
soon with fredo bank two chains and i'm
sure a third artist is probably a female
i don't know but we definitely got two
chances
that's going to be a good remix man free
fredo by the way great guy free freedom
how's your relationship with him because
he's like one of the nicest dudes oh
yeah i mean i've been doing
it's crazy i knew him when he was still
in school like
he used to call me for to get a job
trying to get a job he's like such a
nice dude you know something i know he'd
be wrapped up in some [ __ ] you know but
like when i brought him out he cool i'm
like man
like i say i watched when he first
graduated from high school and they he
you know ended up taking off
and when he when he blew up you know he
ain't changed he ain't changed at all
you know he called me out to the miami
you know invited me to the house gave my
own room and then when i was done you
know so
you know what i'm saying
how big of a deal
for baton rouge to be if webby and
boosie did a whole new album together
they really actually worked they went no
no no no that's what he said he said
that they are talking in there i've been
i'm i'm in the mix today i know they
about did so so so that's going to be a
big deal j book trying to put that
together right now yeah they had to i
heard the songs already how are they hey
just got to put his verse on some of
them and
he got to see him with some but so far
what i heard
do you remember as a kid uh when busy
and webby did the bt awards how [ __ ]
crazy that was oh yeah in 2007 actually
was so ill yeah it was all i remember
that was like a moment for the city
right that was the
dead in hurricane chris
they he boosted them and hurricane chris
had two of the highest and hurricane
chris can rabbit that's my boy he's t
hit me up this
like i don't think people understand i
saw one of his freestyles once oh yeah
or you're a real rapper he could wrap
his ass off he's a real rapper he hit me
up this morning he didn't want to just
talk
did he go to jail for a little bit of
something yeah he had a
little issue he uh he's straight no he's
crazy like i always wonder what happened
to him like why because he's so talented
and he has some joints he uh he he
was the other record he had a baby what
was the other one i know was it i know
no i know you see it was a young jock
what was that he had two right oh
hallelujah
with the motivation you know what i'm
saying and telling me
and it's cool because like i remember
when he was
you know on top on top and that was it
he me he made me feel heavy
like watching louisiana rappers take off
always made me
know i can take over what is the big
difference for people who don't know
because i've only driven through i drift
drove through baton rouge twice but i've
like hung out in new orleans a couple of
times but like culturally it feels like
musically different it's just a whole
different world right yeah new orleans
they they like the cities we call them
the city
they don't they don't the music is
really red all the way very different
they don't they don't
it's like it's louisiana then it's new
orleans um so it's like its own world
world you know we any we so cool with
them but they just so different you guys
i feel like i feel like baton rouge in
like like texas has really always kind
of had more you're kind of more on the
same page new orleans
like they're in a whole other world than
this
um what about your are you working on a
project or y'all got to the mex coming
to the next uh ep uh just a bunch of
turn up songs just feel good music hey
interrupting the interview to tell you
about our good friends at odd socks now
as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying oh shout out to my
bony ass knees um listen go to
oddssocksofficial.com they got all the
craziest socks these are the outsiders
you know what i'm saying they got
spongebob they got cheech and chong
listen breaking bad godfather
whatever you need they got it and now
they have underwear that's right you can
get your odd socks underwear the boxer
briefs are the best underwear that you
could ever fit on your ass trust me when
i tell you these are chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev at checkout
and you'll save 20
off of of your order
underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddsofficial.com keyword bootleg kevin
checkout save twenty percent
how how are you enjoying traveling and
just seeing the world and like doing
club i'm sure you're getting your your
your bag right you know what i'm saying
yeah
right everywhere we go how is it though
man like like just seeing new places and
like going to cities that you never
thought you might go to you know what i
mean i mean it's fun like i remember
i remember i remember was doing shows
for 500
just just a year ago
that's crazy
what's it take to get you to come and do
a club hosting right now just to come
and do a host we gotta do a host for
like 10. come through do your record
yeah we do shows pop some bottles
like
went from 500 to 20 000. that's fire man
in a year well congrats bro what's the
what's the craziest place you've been so
far because of rap music
uh the crazies not even even going crazy
but i had a i had a crazy time at tampa
bay land two weeks ago i used to do
radio in tampa i was in tampa two weeks
ago wait you were there when i was there
you was there when the planes was
somehow messed up
yeah i was there i was there i was there
um
i said no i saw you you were [ __ ]
with my dude buckwheat out there yeah
well yeah i was suppo i was gonna go out
that night it was okay it was lit but i
was there with my family on some
vacations for vacation [ __ ] okay it was
funny you were there the club was fun at
the airport on a saturday night right
yeah yeah no i remember seeing
i remember yeah because i met buckwheat
had posted that he was gonna probably
was like man i'm not gonna go out with
buckwheat tonight or not i'm like nah
i'm staying i was at clearwater beach
yeah cause all the flights was getting
canceled all the fights american
airlines spirit had nothing
we had to drive all the way from
temple to new orleans because that's
where my truck was it
had to get the truck from all the deans
i've made that drive before that's
that's no joke you got to drive too
[ __ ]
straight to houston the next day yeah
that's a mission it was a mission that
was made what what about tampa was wild
besides that no it was terrible straight
we we we went rolling on the boats and
stuff they call it trampa bay i was
looking for tom brady i was trying to
yeah tampa is a special kind of ratchet
man a lot of [ __ ] in tampa in a good
way obviously
they call it trampo bay
there's more strip clubs per capita in
tampa than any other city in the country
now i'm not saying the street clubs are
fighting where they got them but they
got them they're everywhere and i've
seen like two like right across from
each other oh there's like a street uh
dale mabry where there's like eight yeah
yeah they're like all right there i've
seen it
yeah shout out to odyssey 2001 scores uh
i mean i've been to all of them you went
out a little there's a new one out there
that's popping called lookers shout out
my guy i don't like strip clubs why not
i ain't really trying to get no money to
look at you that's fair
would you give money would you would you
if if you knew you could [ __ ] would you
then give the money i probably would
yeah if i had a for shoes well you know
in new york they just decriminalized uh
sex work so you can go to new york and
just you know pay for sex and it's not a
big deal i don't really want to pay for
it though i mean you're going to pay for
it either way right not really make them
pay
you can go on a date i make them pay
you make the girl pay on the payments
because i already taking them on the
days i i got to excuse them what's the
excuse i'm too popular so you won't take
a girl on a date anymore right ain't
going on all day
so how do you get fraternized with women
see i got a big ass house come to my
house
i just i just hooked one you is yours is
your house the kind of house like a
panty dropping house where like if a
girl comes over it's such an impressive
place
she's like i'm ready from the dirty
bikes the trucks the cars the the rooms
have you ever brought a girl over to
your house for the first time and then
went dirt biking with her i tried to
last night we had to catch a flight this
morning
are you still in baton rouge mommy
houston uh smart smart man yeah
houston's great
have you linked up with my boy bfb the
pac-man out there yet no hey my boy
a-red was trying to give me him a
stunning vega stunner for vegas
in the studio last week but i um i had
to leave he's hilarious yeah when i get
back he want me he won't be me pac-man
you know i'm standing for vegas yeah
yeah bb the pac-man is one of the
funniest good like nicest guys i've met
i'ma tell me
soon and he's in houston yeah hey
he's
his his members is my engineer oh fire
one of my engineers
that's dope so you're um like like
moving to houston was that something
where you were like man i gotta get out
the way because i feel like a lot of
times you get the most hate from where
you're from yeah
i look luckily i didn't get to hate
yet right but i knew it was gonna come
sooner later i'm getting 2b like
houston's a great place yeah they got
great strip clubs there i don't like
school clubs i'm aware i'm just saying
if you ever were to try to partake
strippers they manipulate manipulation i
mean that's kind of their job i know
because i'm not about to clone a club
and just and then you got some dudes
who'd be feeling like they did something
like yeah i threw a 10 grand like
yeah you throw it yeah what would you
leave with at the end of the day nothing
you didn't even hit you just live
yeah i i believe in investing my money
something i can get some big other hey
that's smart if i run the club and throw
10 green i'm going to need 10 green
river eggs going home
10 grand worth of ass that's a lot of
eggs that's a lot of ass i i can add up
every dollar i spent on a woman in my
whole life and you know amount to 10
that'd be probably not a thousand
dollars and you're 31 31 i don't know
spend money on women you have children
two oh [ __ ] yeah wait you're 31 and you
haven't spent a thousand dollars in your
life on a woman no
you're a real romantic [ __ ]
aren't you i'll tell you hiding spices
two hottest spices in the small first
[ __ ]
said do you like applebee's because
tonight we're going for that two for 20.
and if you're lucky we'll go to the
second half of the menu and it's 2 for
30. but that's only if i like you if you
really really really wrong i'll take you
to something nice but wait what's
something nice chili's nah
get her the blooming onion a girl a girl
tried to get me to take her to take her
to a real chris but i'm like [ __ ] you
like you even came from for chris but
you want me to take
so i ain't taking but if i could tell
like you
you up you top notch you got your [ __ ]
together i'll take it
what's your deal breaker with a chick
so like if you let's say you start
talking to a girl right yeah let's say
she comes over and some ha like what is
it is it is what's the deal breaker
what's the one thing that'll make you be
like ah no no no i'm good i'm not
hitting is it is it uh bad breath is it
uh her feet ain't done is it i don't
like nasty feet uh feet got to be right
but i mean i think my dear breaker with
females is
when you come to my house and get this
and get to singing my songs
oh my god
yeah i hate that like come on bro we're
not doing it like you might you're
showing me you're giving me fan vibes
back in the day uh when i was single i
went to a girl's house
and she had uh two pet snakes and a
ferret and i left
yeah they was locked up yeah but i was
just like i can't what kind of what kind
of [ __ ] got two snakes and a ferret at
our house that's weird though that's a
weird-ass broad right like what am i
doing here get me the [ __ ] out of here
i mean mine is depending on where you
stay if you i ain't going to your house
really
i used to pick this girl that stayed in
the hood mm-hmm and i used to be like
[ __ ] i got a
gun on my left
it's just too dangerous you know what's
in the uber
oh we have uber back then it's like
2005.
yeah it's different times yeah now i i
don't like to send an uber because these
they be dropping their locations
yeah you got to watch them these days
you know what i'm saying they get to the
house and want to drop the low
till they home girl they brought her he
stayed next thing you know something
missing
yeah has that happened to you before
uh nah i'm really selective about how
you let over yeah
that's tough man very very nowadays you
know how these you know you you you
might trust somebody yeah it gets tricky
so i kind of like
weave all those people out like the
girls
like if i let a girl come to my house
it's a girl i probably been knew all
i've been right been locked in with but
just meeting random new females so for a
future reference if a girl's watching
this she can't come to your house and
sing your song because you'll kick her
out
i probably won't kick y'all but i
thought i hit you i'm probably done with
you like because i know what you you
just you know
yeah
i actually met a girl like three months
ago who didn't know who i was
and i got a number we got the kicking it
over
it was after the fact she she found out
who i was
and i'm like i'm cool that's so because
you know that you're like she wasn't
there for the wrong reason with the rest
of them be
oh you hd you know they i was literally
last i was just like
last week a girl dm me like
oh i've been had a crush on you i like
you so i d on the back like you know
let's let's link up so i never didn't
link up with her
but her her ex-boyfriend in my inbox
sending me a screenshot
of her talking to her friend talking
about girl gets me in my inbox
like wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait crazy okay so you had a girl hit
you up she hit me up like first hey i've
been a fan you hit her back hey let's
kick it what's up her
ex-boyfriend then hit you up and was
like this screenshot of her
she tried to she
she didn't delete her messages to her
friend mm-hmm so she dealing with a
friend like girl guess who's been girl
hd being in my inbox all day i'm like we
only sent four messages so her ex
boyfriend is obviously salty
he wouldn't trip he was just let me i
know oh you know him yeah he
so you're [ __ ] with your homeboy
homeboy i ain't never [ __ ] with i
just was about to heal her ah but
she is that against dude code no he like
i don't know but we we we
do my homeboy homeboy show me oh you're
so he's your homie's homie my homeboy is
his homeboy okay so i ain't we you guys
let me ask you this hypothetically
speaking before you would have [ __ ]
his ex would you have hit him up and be
like hey i'm about i was gonna tell him
okay i thought he do after you hit yeah
i ain't gonna tell you before because
then you can act surprised you could be
like yo i didn't even know man i just
want you to know i [ __ ] shorty man i
didn't even know until like no i had to
finish yours on some slick [ __ ] so i i
ain't fell back from
did he send me a screenshot of her
taking her hunger and she was like uh
yeah hd been in my inbox all day he ugly
but i get some money from him what so i
was i so she called me acting like she
she don't know i know what she knows
so she called me on some [ __ ] like oh i
think my instagram got head cuz he got
my message out
i like you for real i just was talking
[ __ ] to my own girl like who the [ __ ]
talk she saying some [ __ ] like that like
you you really clown chasing on some
[ __ ] super she's in this conversation
who was stan
but guess how she ended the conversation
um can i still talk to you i still want
to talk to you and you said no i was
like she said come on now i'm just going
to hit you just because you know
did you end up delivering i mean i ain't
been back i ain't she back in bed
what's the difference between like like
baton rouge women and houston women
houston women got more brains better
women think the same they all
crabs in the bucket
if you talk to one up late for the 17
friends and say great y'all to talk to
me
it feels like baton rouge is like kind
of got a small town vibe to it so
probably everybody kind of know
everybody yeah i can't i can't deal
nobody back from bedrooms they're gonna
say i've been in it i was hd was in my
dms and i be we'd be talking about
regular [ __ ] though like you know i
won't even be shooting my stick
i'd just be talking baby somebody
shooting your stick like trying to go
with the move on the grill okay okay
i'll just be probably like you probably
talking about some regular [ __ ] but
they're gonna sum it up like oh he was
in my dms
you know would you have you ever
like what what's like the
you know the extent you'll go to sliding
into chick's dms
like if you just see a chick and she's
hot will you just be like like put the
eyeballs or the old me yeah i just slide
on everything bad
now would you subscribe to their only
fans first no i would never i'm not
spending money on females i didn't know
you know maybe you're saying
just so you know i support your hustle
oh nah now we're gonna get you another
hustle
that's the case
i'm not supporting no i don't do that
it's kind of like it's it's it's it's
the virtual strip club right
you know like virtually anything dealing
with women you don't like anything you
can get your money back on i got to get
something back yeah i'm sorry
what what about you know are you
investing your money wisely right now
are you doing anything with your bread
outside of you know buying two watches
oh yeah this i mean these this you had
these prior this prize but like what are
you doing to put this new with this i
got a lot going on i got my llc's uh i
got my homeboys i got a clothing line
i'm getting together okay i'm looking
i'm feeling i'm about to get in this
real estate [ __ ] or fire uh i'm i'm more
of a i like to see my people eat so i'm
trying to i'm trying to get some
apartments and houses on section eight
let the government pay for it and then
my people are there
because then you you got that building
are you going to try to do the section
anything and i want to do whatever
everywhere everywhere anywhere i can go
in
i ain't limited to myself nowhere
yeah
where
trying to give me a couple trucks going
you know what i'm saying when's your ep
coming out
uh i think it at the at the top and top
of the next the top of next year i think
top of next year i i don't know don't
confirm it after the two chains fredo
bang remix comes out
after the remix the touchdown i'm a
[ __ ] psychic it's
it's a few artists are you close
you close
you close are you close close enough i
got two out of three
it's got two out of three
all right we got confirmation there it
is
there it is you close oh man that's what
i like to man
good i'm really looking forward to the
remakes man oh yeah was it is it like is
it i mean you know having two chains on
a remix is a big deal man like two
chain's a [ __ ] legend yeah like a
legend and we ain't gonna talk about
that because i've never seen his own i
said you know you just did you just said
i got two out of three see use clothes
yeah no well you got a little
you know yeah shout out to two things
though uh who in your opinion is on the
mount rushmore of baton rouge hip hop
four people
boosie
webby
young boy
[Music]
and kevin
okay
i gotta go with kevin kevin kevin the
hillborders yeah i think he also doesn't
get enough love as far as like
just his career has been crazy crazy i
think i don't know
being from baton rouge
is different they don't understand us
they don't understand us like we
i think we too emotionally
i mean yeah if you think about it like
and i'm saying we not me myself but
just as a whole like
i was our whole state like we
we like come out we really emotional so
ain't that the industry not gonna
understand that real [ __ ] no kevin is an
emotional guy uh i don't know i mean me
and dj had interviewed him
and he had touched his shoulder
and he was like hey
don't touch me
don't touch me
i haven't moved this way
or an hour later like 10 minutes later
he literally
was so intense and did not [ __ ] with us
with the cameras but look check this out
that interview happened it went viral as
[ __ ] but right people don't realize
right after that interview ended and the
cameras turned off we sat there with him
for like two hours and shot the [ __ ] and
he played his album and he was like man
i wish we would have started the
interview now because now i [ __ ] with
y'all i mean bro it's kevin that's k
i've been new kevin look
i've been looking i've been to new
orleans that's a hell of a four artists
though coming out of baton rouge i'm
just speaking i'm just speaking as far
as impact i agree like
for his impact
my my favorites would be probably be
different but now but that's the fourth
wise you know i got to get something
like young boy he did some [ __ ] that
ain't never been done no he's a i mean i
even think somehow he's underappreciated
yeah i think the numbers he does his
numbers don't mess his his his his
flowers he's here
i just think people like
i think sometimes people get turned off
by a young boy because of like i can see
i got attitudes yeah but at the same
time he's like bro he's he's doing
better than the bigger numbers and oh
damn near everybody he really is like
he he one of the ones ain't gonna lie
like he i mean i like i say off camera
some dudes be straight to me like
i i i can i don't ran it with a young
boy for
an hour straight off camera like
when the cameras come on it's like they
got to get they
you know they got you know they got to
protect they bring or protect the image
so they don't you know they don't want
anybody feeling like they saw for they
not cut like this [ __ ] so
because people be trying to as far as
like the type of music he make you got
people who want to fly oh he i'ma test
this gangster and ain't them dudes ain't
[ __ ] like them ain't [ __ ] so
you coming off trying to test this man
gangster he gonna show you
you know
me on the other hand i'm so laid back
man i did all the gangsters you can
think about what you want to do i'm not
trying to do that no more yeah i think
it's it's tough man because it's so much
a part of his image but i also think
like sometimes
when you put that out there this was th
that's what that's just it comes back to
you that's the energy yeah yeah i try to
guess why i go out with different
energies
yeah for sure and even like you know
like uh
there's so many young artists like i i
had a young and ace up here and i was
like bro like you're dope you've been
dope you're like man the energy that
them jacksonville boys are putting out
into the world is insane
they going crazy they're going [ __ ] i
thought chicago was [ __ ]
right like we had julio and him up here
and i'm like guys like y'all got a chill
out there they're going crazy like what
the [ __ ] they're going crazy it's like
[ __ ] shyrock 2.0 yeah they're going
crazy out there
you done any shows in jacksonville uh no
i haven't done anything i've been
getting phones that might be the back i
turned down i'm like you know what i
ain't a lot of [ __ ] with jacksonville no
shout out to duval but i mean i just
might not i don't know if i'm gonna i
don't know i [ __ ] miles car no he's
from jacksonville i think young
they're another city that's having a big
a big moment
florida is a whole lot like florida yeah
florida kodak gnome jack what like all
of them so hot boy
what i like about florida right now is
before it was only miami and a little
bit of broward county that was here now
the whole state
just doing anything whatever part of the
statement
they got somebody from jacksonville
tampa got a taliban dude of this fire uh
yeah i mean obviously saint pete's right
there right away
yeah shout out to uh to florida look man
let's introduce the single for the radio
show man so introduce the record let's
get into it going crazy on tick tock
the number one record on the tick tock
to be clear to be clear cuz y'all don't
i don't think nobody don't know
two million videos got deleted
because we was dealing with uh copyright
um from the whole version yeah when they
when they put the song out when we put
the song he was picking up can't stop
jigging
so the girl who originated originally
put it on tick tock her tick tock got
deleted so we lost two million
video videos and we still did crazy
numbers that's crazy so if you add them
too many videos number one number one
but yeah touchdown calls
for president mr ball ball ball nine
nine nine nine you know all that that's
me let's go man it's the bullet cap show